hello everyone and welcome back to the
russian chess championship we said that
we were going to cover at least uh one
of the games uh by ian pomnishi the
winner of the 2020
uh russian chess championship and here's
a very nice game
i believe from the second round he's
playing against russian grandmaster
mikhail antipov
and it's quite the game and uh features
a
a very a very exciting moment so without
further ado
let's check it out so uh antipov with
the white pieces
opens with e4 sorry about that uh we
have
c5 and nipple goes for the sicilian
defense knight to f3
and d6 we have d4 striking in the center
so the open sicilian
uh captures on d4 captures and now
knight to f6 we have knight c3
and now a6 uh the neighbor of defense
and there are
uh so many moves you can play here so
many lines like
there literally isn't a bad move you can
play in this position like
even b4 is a move here it's been played
in in top tier chess but other moves
like let's say bishop e3 bishop g5
bishop b2 bishop c4
uh h3 g3 f3 f4 a3
all all very possible moves and here in
this game uh antipov goes for a3 so it's
not
as uh popular as let's say bishop g5 or
bishop to a2 or moves like that but it
is played a lot
so here uh black continues with e5
chasing away the knight on d4
and knight to f3 and even though
uh well the candidates tournament has
been postponed let's not forget
uh yanni pomnishi is one of the
candidates in the candidates tournament
and not only that he is currently the
leader alongside maxime barcia lagrave
so h6 by black taking away the g5 square
from white's pieces
and now bishop to c4 and here bishop to
e6 immediately challenging this bishop
and now there is a notable game that
reached this exact same position in 2019
uh between nigel short and uh
uh eleven aaron where bishop captures on
e6 was played uh
11 was able to win that game but here we
have bishop to b3
and it is already as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game
so basically white is saying uh i'm
perfectly fine define
defending my bishop this way and even if
you capture uh you've messed up my pawn
structure a little bit but i don't mind
i'm gonna develop my bishop bring my
rook to c
c one have a nice open c file for my
rook and it's not not a problem for
white
so nipple of course doesn't uh bother
himself with this he just continues
development
knights to c6 and here we have castles
by antipov
uh rook the c8 and nipple brings the
rook to the c file
and now h3 uh or like black taking away
that the g4 square from black's pieces
but also preparing this maneuver knights
to h2 to g4
uh bishop to e7 and now knights to h2
with
castles by nipple and now knights to g4
so white is definitely trying uh here he
antipo wants to really make use of the
white pieces and he wants to put a lot
of pressure
uh on uh yanipan issue so here knight
captures on g4 nepal trades here h
captures and now bishop to g5 so now
nipple doubled up white's g pawns and
it's uh
well it's it's not your everyday
position he now wants to trade some
pieces
uh and uh for example you he can trade
here he can trade here he can bring the
knight to d4 and he's gonna
have a very very nice position so knight
to d5 and
now comes knight to d4 now putting more
pressure on the bishop on b3
we have c3 challenging the knight uh now
giving up the bishop
and uh here before trading bishop
captures on c1 we have rook captures and
only now
knight captures on b3 queen captures on
b3 now attacking the b7 pawn but nepo
just goes after the g4 pawn
so queen captures on b7 and now rook to
b8 attacking the queen once the queen
moves uh
black wants to capture on b2 so queen
captures on a6
rook captures on b2 and here we have
this position
the material on the board is completely
equal and with all this
uh well new move stuff and some
maneuvering uh antipovega position where
he has a past a pawn
and if he can get his rook for example
to a1 start pushing that pawn
could be very good for him however here
you can go rook to a1 right away because
bishop
e2 just wins material as the rook and
queen will be under attack
so here uh he first has to deal with
this so he goes rook to b1 he
wants to trade a pair of rooks uh or
force this rook to move but uh nipple
immediately goes bishop to e2
and now the rook and the queen are under
attack and this is the critical moment
of our game
but we are going to return to this
position later on so we're just going to
show you
what actually happened in the game so
here uh of course you have to move the
queen so queen to c6 was played
and uh this is not the greatest of moves
but like i said
uh we're gonna revisit this position
so queen to c6 getting the queen out of
harm's way and now comes
rook to d2 by nippo uh the rook on f1 is
still under attack
rook to e1 uh and now queen to g5 with
some very nasty ideas like bishop to f3
followed by queen captures and g2
checkmate
and although you could play something
like knights the e3 to guard
this pawn here then you still go bishop
to f3
and once you play something basically
black wants to play rook to d3
capture the knight remove the defender
of the g2 pawn and chuck made the white
king
so here queen c4 guarding against rook
to d3 but now
queen h4 threatening queen captures on
f2
you have to defend this queen to f1 and
now we get bishop captures on e4 and
it's a very very crazy position where
white doesn't really have all that much
to hope for it's it's all black uh
fro from this point on so instead after
queen to g5 we have
rook captures on e2 and gives up the
exchange and he says okay you can
capture and then maybe i can do
something with my past a pawn
so here we have rook captures on e2 and
now queen captures on v6 so grabbing yet
another pawn
and creating yet another pass pawn uh
and here
rook the e8 by nipple rook the d8 would
be a terrible mistake it seems like a
nice move as the queen guards the rook
but knight e7
check and you're gonna lose that rook so
after queen uh captures on the e6 we
have rook to e8
and now comes queen to d7 attacking the
rook and the rook the e6 nepal says
uh i don't mind giving you the back rank
because after check i can simply move my
king and i'm perfectly fine here and i
want to play rook to g6 and then put
even more pressure on white's king so
here g3
and now comes queen to h5 so well
what do you do here uh here king to g2
was played
uh if you try something like knight to
e7 check which does make sense
for example king h7 and queen to d8
going after queen to g8
checkmate uh nipple would simply give
back the exchange here
rook captures queen captures and now
queen to f3
go after the pawn and once you defend
this rook captures on e4 and it's again
a very very ugly position for white to
play
uh h5h4 coming not much for white to to
hope for here
so instead after queen to h5 and try to
kink the g2
now you can maybe even bring the other
rook over here
uh but here comes king to h7 and now
queen to d8 by white also if you try
rook to h1 here just uh
attacking the queen for the moment it's
not possible uh because rook captures an
f2 with
check you have to capture and then just
queen captures on h1 not
not the greatest of moves so queen to d8
by antipov and now comes queen to g4
now preparing rook to g6 so rook to b4
there really aren't all that many better
moves you could try with queen to h4
but then just after for example queen h4
you can trade captures captures and
captures and
this is just a lost end game for white
uh he's down the exchange and
very soon will be down at least a pawn
or two
so instead after queen to g4 rook to b4
was played but here
nipple just played rook to g6 and he was
in this position on move 30
uh that mikhail antipov resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here queen captures
uh not there queen captures and g3 is
the threat because the rook
pins the f2 pawn you will not be able to
capture and uh whatever you play let's
taking g1
you un pin still just queen h3
threatening checkmate and
once you block this rook to be one uh
just rook capture
three f captures and the queen to g2 now
will be checkmate
so after this rook to g6 move antipov
resigned and uh a great victory for
yanni pomnishi
but i said that we were gonna return to
this position after rook to b1 so here
bishop to e2 was played by nipple and
now i want you to really
uh you know really pause the video here
and try to find a good move for
uh for antipov as it's uh it's a very
tricky position
and you know it's a very very rich
position
so to say so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move or moves
uh for white while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh you have just
found uh
one one of the two brilliant defensive
ideas in this position
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show we're first going to show
queen to a7 so queen to c6 was played in
the game of course you have to move the
queen it's under attack
queen to a7 is one such option and now
if we try the same idea that nipple used
in the game
uh rook to d2 preparing queen to g5 you
just play
knight to e7 check and with this move
you block the queen's access to the g5
square for example king h7
rook f the e1 now and after bishop moves
the bishop g4 you can you want to bring
the bishop back to e6 for example
rook to b7 a nice rook lift bishop to e6
in the now the other rook can come to a1
and now you can start pushing your past
a pawn
and the white's position is simply
simply great
another idea here after bishop to e2
instead of queen to a7 is the very trick
is c4 but it's a
it's such a such a nice idea so again if
you capture on f1 then rook captures on
b2 so here
rook to d2 we repeat nipple's idea uh
from the game
now rook f2 e1 and now if you now go
queen to g5 it's not a problem because
rook to b3
this is the idea of the pawn to c4 push
you open up the rook's access to the g3
square
so it's a very very sneaky defensive
idea so queen to g5 wouldn't make much
sense here we would probably go
something like bishop to d3
and then rook b to d1 threatening the
rook uh you have to capture otherwise
you lose the bishop so captures captures
and bishop captures on e4
so black wins upon but only very
temporarily as
knight to c3 attacks the bishop and now
opens up a double attack here
and once again white will uh have not
one pass pawn but two pass pawns because
after the bishop moves let's say
rook attacks it bishop goes back now we
play
c5 and black cannot capture due to the
pin
and even if queen to g5 going after the
rook here
we just play queen captures on d6 defend
our rook and now we have two
pass pawns which are ready to be pushed
forward uh
black black will probably hold this but
white has uh
well will put a lot of pressure on
black's position now
so these were uh antipost options after
bishop to e2 by nipple but he chose
queen to c6 and then after that
the position was simply too too
difficult to defend
especially against a player of nepal's
caliber
so that's uh the game i was going
through games and i
was trying to figure out which one to
show and then i saw this position with
with all of these possibilities queen c6
queen and queen a7 and even the c4 movie
and i
i thought you guys maybe would enjoy
this one so i hope i did not make a
mistake maybe i'm going to show another
one
we'll see us uh but you know for for now
we just have this one
and uh yeah it's also interesting uh
nipple had a lot more time on the clock
when the game ended almost an
hour but he's usually an incredibly fast
player but i wonder who who ran into
whose
preparation here and also so we don't
forget here are the final standings uh
if we don't show any more games uh of
the
russian championship uh 2020 so in first
place
yanni pomiche with seven and a half out
of eleven uh second place sergey karakin
who had an opportunity to
uh even win the championship had he won
his game at
uh against daniel dubo uh in the final
round but who just played
the most brilliant game of the
tournament is the previous video that
i've shown
if you still haven't seen it it will be
the first link in the description below
it's just a mind-blowing game do check
it out
uh then uh vladimir ferrosev and the
daniel dubois were shared in third place
maxim chicaive and the vladislav artemy
of uh
fifth and sixth uh then with five and a
half uh peter swiddler and nikita
vettigov uh andre esipenko
and the moxie matako with five with
three and a half alexey goganov and
mikhail antipov uh in last place with
two out of 11.
so those were the standings and that was
uh the game i do hope you guys enjoyed
that
i'm not gonna use this for a thumbnail
definitely they're gonna spoil too much
uh but yeah really really hope you guys
enjoyed it and all of that uh you know
craziness that happened that that could
have happened after bishop to e2 move
uh i would like to thank young monsieur
david kimura
hbd abdul meaning happy birthday abdul
uh william welsh and gregory novak for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing perhaps
the uh coverage after it's already over
of the russian championship
checking up on your waterfall
suggestions and whatever happens uh in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day